hello everyone and welcome back to the
finals of the magnus carlson chess store
this is match five and if you don't know
what's been happening so far uh the
first four matches were
really really awesome and the result is
now equal
so two uh two points magnus two points
in car and now this is match five and we
are
we have a lot of interesting games that
we can show today but uh we're gonna
start with the armageddon game which
means that
after six games after four games of
rapid and two games of blitz
uh the result was a tie and now we have
the armageddon game
and tomorrow uh we're going to show the
other
two games one or two games uh uh not
still not
deciding and i'm not gonna tell you how
uh
the games went and not spoiled too much
but uh that's why we're starting with
armageddon
so magnus as he qualified to the
uh grand final by winning uh one of the
events
he gets to choose which color of the
pieces he wants in the armageddon
and here he chose white everyone thought
he was going to choose black because
everyone chooses black in armageddon
but he chose white he uh
i will mention why in in in my next
video but not for now so magnus with the
white pieces opens with d4
which means in armageddon magnus needs a
win and if it's a draw then he car wins
the match so knight to f6 with c4
uh e6 and the knight to c3 magnus
invites hikaru to go for the nimzo
indian uh which hikaru does so bishop to
b4
and now a3 they are challenging the
bishop we have captures captures and
now c5 so the same variation of the
nimzo is on the board
uh we have e3 and knight to c6
bishop to d3 and now we have castles
uh we have knights to e2 uh and uh now
comes
b6 so preparing to fianchetto the light
square bishop uh with
e4 by magnus and now knight to the e8 uh
in expectancy of f4 hikaru uh makes room
for the f5 pawn
so castles by magnus and now bishop to
a6
uh putting pressure on the c4 point you
want to play knight to the a5 and bring
another attacker to the c4 pawn
so f4 by magnus and now f5 by higaro
immediately stopping that f1 with e
captures on f5
e captures and now d captures on c5
so magnus opening up files uh he does
have the two bishops
but the uh the as peter liko said the
pawn structure
is uh is pretty weird so be captures
hikaru recaptures and now bishop to e3
and okay now the bishop player is very
active this
this point is under attack the knight is
coming to the g3 you can attack it again
the c5 pawn is under attack
so he car defends it with the d6 and now
knight to g3
magnus goes after the f5 pawn we have g6
he chiro defends it
and now rook to e1 with knight to f6
now as these squares have been weakened
the knight can come to g4 or e4 if
needed
and here comes the bishop to f2
opening up the e file for the rook so
some nice rook lifts might be possible
and he car stops it with queen d7
this position has been reached one
before once before
in 2013 young she used to do that tried
rook to b8 here
uh and we got a draw with the move but
here queen the d7 by hikaru is a new
move so already as of
17 now we have a completely new game so
let's see how magnus deals with this he
goes knight f1
uh probably the idea is to shift the
knight over to d5
which is a nice central square so
knight's the a5 with
a double attack uh on the c4 pawn and
now we have
bishop to h4 now uh probably
going after the knight to remove one of
the defenders of the d5 square maybe
then you can uh get your knight all the
way to d5
however we have rook eight to e8 uh
offering a rook trade here
magnus trades once captures captures and
now bishop captures an f6 so the knight
is eliminated
rook captures on f6 and now queen to f3
with ideas
maybe if the knight captures uh then you
can go queen d5 check
claim it uh as the bishop also attacks
d4 however it's not really an issue
hikaru could go for this and even if
queen d5 check you can block with queen
f7 everything is nicely defended if
captures then captures everything is
perfectly fine
uh however he first just prepares it
rook to e6 he wants to get his rook to
e1 he's not worried about this pawn
uh it's very unlikely that you will be
able to to guard
this pawn so he he'll probably pick it
up later so
rook the b1 by magnus now with ideas of
bringing the rook over to the to the
back rank if the queen moves
and only now does hikaru go after the
pawn bishop captures on c4 we have
bishop captures and
knight characters so ikaru is now up
upon and also attacking the a3 pawn so
magnus advances it with a4 and now king
g7
he carved off the pawn now he just needs
to make sure that magnus doesn't have
any attacking chances and
all will be well uh and here we have
queen to b7 check by magnus so very
interesting was rook the b7 check
and if king f6 g4 however uh
incredible as it is the king is very
safe here for example if you go rook to
e1
g5 check you have the e6 square and even
though the black king has no squares
that he can use the the king is actually
very safe here you don't have
you don't have uh ways of of attacking
the black king well
uh while it's on e6 although it looks
incredibly weird
so what you could do after king to f6
you could go real captures an a7 create
a past a pawn
but then again rookie one game continues
and it's uh you know
anything anything can happen uh but
magnus doesn't like a rook the g
rook to b7 check so instead he goes
queen to b7
check and now of course hikaru blocks
queen to f7
now not allowing queen captures on a7 we
have queen to a6
and now rook to e7 uh
with with a double defense on the a7
pawn rook the b8 as now uh
nakamura left the defense of the back
rank and now king h6 hikaru finds a nice
safe haven for for his king
with h3 now maybe hoping for some g4 g5
ideas in the future if possible
but now queen e6 by hikaru with ideas
of trading the knights knight d2 coming
uh combined with quinta e3 check might
be coming
so rook the a8 now magnus wants to
eliminate this pawn so you can see that
magnus is wasting a lot of time uh with
this plan
queen b7 check queen a6 bringing the
rook to b8 to here just to win the a7
pawn
if he wanted to win it he could have
done it right away with with rogue b7
followed by captures instead
uh but okay knight to d2 by hikaru nice
tactical shot because now if the knight
is traded then the queen check
trades off the knights and then the rook
also now comes into the attack
of course completely winning for hikaru
so instead we have rooked the d8 by
magnus
putting pressure on the d6 pawn as well
and now we have
knight captures on f1 and now the
problem is you don't have time to
capture with the king because queen e1
is checkmate
so magnus forced to go back with the
queen and now hikaru just goes queen to
e3 check
king h2 and now rook to e4 uh
going for queen captures on f4 and now
of course he wants to trade queens
uh so rook captures on v6 by magnus and
now
a queen trait occurs queen captures with
captures captures and
now a5 uh magnus continues pushing his a
pawn and still
his plan consists of eliminating the a7
pawn and then advancing his
uh a5 pawn so again uh claiming that
with
that rugby seven check it was the way to
go if this was the plan
so rook the c4 hikaru also wants to
create a passport and now rook to a6
with rook captures on c3 rook captures
on a7
and now rook to a3 hikaru now puts a
rook behind
the carlson's pass pawn and king g1
magnus now needs to bring the king into
the game and uh
in the same game in this rook and pawn
in game he's down a pawn
which is usually not a problem but it is
a big problem if you if you have to win
the game to win the match as
once again this is armageddon so c4 he
car
starts pushing his pass pawn and now
king f2 rookie to check if magnus wants
to move the king then he loses the king
side pawns if he wants to defend them
then the c pawn just marches down the
board so king e3
magnus decides to abandon the g2 pawn
hikaru captures
it and now queen d4 king d4 uh we have
rook to h2 going for this pawn as well
and now
a6 uh with rook captures on h3 and king
captures on c4 and now
he carried with three points on the king
side and magnus would have very well
advanced
pawn on the queen side and if he could
just push it a little bit further that
would be great however
hikaru is in time to play rook to a1 so
here we have rook d7
rook to a1 going after the pawn and now
king b5
defending the past pawn with king the g5
he
offers up this pawn so he can just start
pushing his own pawn
and rook to d for now now magnus doesn't
allow hikaru to advance with the king
but of course
f4 and here we have rook to a4 by magnus
saying that okay now i have a rook
behind a pass pawn
uh and i want you to move the rook and
push the pawn however
this is not winning for hikaru and i'm
sure you know why but just in case uh
feel free to pause the video and
win the game for hikaru while i give you
a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on
precisely calculating all the way to the
end game and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show uh it's
rook captures on a4 and now of course uh
king capture sun a4 was played with f3
by hikaru and now
a7 with f2 and now a8 magnus queen's
first
but it's of a little comfort as hikaru
also queens and he is still
up to pawn so here magnus played queen
d5 check we have queen to f5 and now
magnus played queen today to check
probably to get hikaru to end the game
quickly and of course hikaru just
blocked with
queen to f4 check nicely connecting and
it was in this position that magnus
carlson resigned the game
and match five goes to hikaru so this
means he car released three to two in
matches
and uh we have uh two more matches
happening or if hikaru wins the next one
then he's the champion and
magnus now needs to win the second match
to force match seven
and then try and win this whole thing so
we'll see what happens
here of course you resign because after
the queens are traded off you're just up
to connected past pawns there's no
there's no playing this so yeah really
really amazing stuff
like i said uh there were a lot of games
possible to show here i'm gonna try and
show at least one or two tomorrow before
the start of the sixth match uh and yeah
uh once again uh i do hope you enjoyed
it uh i would like to thank uh
victor pesto um gomez um
[Music]
uh john class for constantin kopenko uh
and kelly mcdonald for your contribution
to my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it and i would also like to
uh wish uh um uh benjamin halberg for
a happy birthday i wish you all the best
and uh you know may you have a great
year and you know everything that goes
with it and many victories
over the board so uh once again i do
hope you enjoyed it uh
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the finals
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day